[Music]
wake up early in the morning press play
and let's get it
in cause we rocking with the fighter and
he
[Music]
look at us me and cat are wearing gray
you guys wearing black oh
happy black history month so happy
valentine's
day love is what love is love is right
mm-hmm
is that the new love is tight
valentine's day yes i just did a drop
this morning man chappelle
just dropped this morning oh my gosh
didn't get the black memo no you did not
but i guess valentine's day memo
oh you did you know nothing about these
strange love donkeys those are dope
how about when these dropped last
valentine's day i [ __ ] up and hit
double on my cart uh-huh and then i you
know i get alerts on my phone whenever
purchases so it came down like what the
[ __ ] they charged me how much for these
and then i look i had two i'm like oh
[ __ ] it's too late to cancel so i called
jam like yo i got you these strange
loves
so they send both pairs i paid like 400
if you go on uh
stockx now i think it's 1400 pairs 1600
pair
for those yeah is it is that based off
depeche mode i don't think so
because there was something called
strange love yeah or
strange love is a company or a yeah
company oh i thought it was from
department
velvet crush velvet so yeah yeah the
material is special
yeah and the monster sucks you dirt bike
now or what i was sponsored by monster
for
oh you are years for of oh wow
x games oh no xk you're just slipping
just look at hey how the workouts going
bro oh you know what's up
217. you gotta tat it because if i go to
reach for i didn't get a tattoo just
drop draw it on there with a pen every
morning
if i go to reach if i go to reach for a
cookie let's no
no too big for some paint for that
cookie day three of the diet song
yeah man every every meal i have i snap
a pic i
he'll texted a mike much take this away
add this
um you still hold me accountable dude
never been more serious about today
okay okay dude my boy hella mark harley
kicked my ass the other day man i worked
out with him
thank you oh the video
how about you send that to the group
chat and jay goes he looks weird he goes
that's a weird looking fella
weird-looking i said that was a sexy
[ __ ]
look at him bro he's just [ __ ] huge
how do i get that [ __ ] he makes jay
look like a [ __ ] earthworm next time
i mean he is a sexy looking dude yeah he
kicks my ass
could have been a werewolf in true blood
yes oh
i can see him fighting you know he's not
natural though yeah you know he's not
natural
him yeah that's natural i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding i'm just kidding
listen i'm all for it bubba do your
thing i got tests coming today check on
my testosterone levels hga
all that stuff because of what happened
to you yeah with the uh
trt yep so mike dolce is like we need to
know where exactly where you're at
yeah i think you're running blood now
urine mm-hmm
everything hold on you ever you ever
think about stuff like that
nah also a lot of people all my skinny
boys we repping
uh isn't stick boys not stick boys i
like boys um
they was like yo you're not an ectomorph
i'm a mesmo morph they're not what's
that means
your skinny friends are [ __ ] stupid
i'd be a mesomorph
mesomorph nothing so there's
ectomorph is someone has trouble put on
weight and is uh
genetically thin okay an endomorph is
someone who's in the middle
yes old school
morph is someone who's
what oh no we're not morphing into
anything chapelle i get what you're
saying
there it is right here that's the people
there's a bunch of different ones that
are kind of similar so like
ectomorph yeah that's come on i do not
look like
you and brian like you guys are like you
have trouble put on weight
you're thin low fat level uh noble
muscles
medium or large large bone you're not
broad shoulders you see my you saw my
shoulders
so an ectomorph is low level fat that's
you
um narrow shoulders and flat chest
that's you and brian
thin and long limbs that's you and brian
um
so the middle the endomorph low fat
level no swole muscles
not me medium or large bone definitely
on the large side broad shoulders
check and then endomorph excessive fat
yep
major bone and massive limbs yeah yeah
short arms and legs
nope definitely so it's like you and i
are indo and
mezzo like indo and mezzo had a baby
we're in between them we're in between
them
and i'm like ectomorphic yeah i think
it's tough you know
that that endomorph the one on the far
right it's got that v line
yeah i ain't got that you got that v i
don't got that v i've seen it
they're using the same model for all of
them i don't know if every endomorph has
that though we'll talk
now if you just take the ectomorph legs
and put it on a mesmo morph
then that you have you could get to the
middle one
i'm almost there you're trying you're
trying hey listen i give you props
all right i'll give you a credit we're
credited how how's your diet been
chappelle been great i've been on it
doug my girl guess that's
actually i had a bad meal yesterday you
did yeah she gets no bad meals
i guess chick-fil-a no it was i went to
this vegan joint called crossroads
i love melrose yeah that travis barker's
place he owns that
oh really it's so funny because i was
with my boy who's also my boy toby
morris
who's also friends with travis barker
and then travis like
he posted a picture of all of us there
and travis was like yo where's my invite
not to me but to him he's like yeah i
own it where's my i didn't know that
yeah is he vegan
yeah oh [ __ ] i didn't know that i think
i might do it vegan
yeah oh my dab one is it tough have you
done it i did it i've done
it all yeah you yeah i feel like you've
done every [ __ ]
never been so serious i can't i can't
there's no cheat meals for me
in this i'm gonna wait i'm gonna give it
a lot hot got it if i do two meal
i'm gonna be so strict man yeah
eventually eventually you could get to
cheat meal yes
that's what mike dolce said he's like
dude we it has to be a habit you gotta
create a
habit and then we can start and we're
gonna get you to the weight you want to
be
then you can start [ __ ] around with
cheat meals because until then
we're not doing cheap sound like
richardson uh my boy mark i've seen him
eat
a [ __ ] large pizza like we would uh
he invited me over for the fights one
time
okay he ordered two large ass pizzas
full egg pizza
i don't know where it's from somewhere
in the valley out in sherman oaks
the pizza was great i couldn't even
finish it he finished his whole [ __ ]
thing he's on different
supplements but like so what so what he
would what he does though
like he won't eat for the rest of the
day i don't know if that's advice like
he'll he'll
he'll fast he'll fast for a while
there'll be justice calories that day
yeah yeah
like but like i mean obviously he's
eating other stuff like before
dolce was funny because we talked for
about an hour and he's like
so give me your general run down like
well i fast in the morning
and how long have you been fasting i go
[ __ ] even when i was fighter i was
fasting he was
and uh how's that working out for you is
your body where you need to be i go
no it's never really working because if
you keep doing that yeah well that's
insane
yeah because that's insane why would you
not eat so you don't have to fast
no it does it's not for everybody yeah
it's not for everybody so you
so all we got to do is just find what
works best for our body type it's
working
what your butt look you look good i know
you look good
remember like you look good no i don't
remember that you gotta lose some
you gotta lose some weight oh i i i this
we both yeah that's why i can talk to
you later
we both will die i gotta fight right now
i'm day three of yeah and the water
intake's insane
how's the non-stop how your digestive
system are y'all passing gasses
oh my gosh what happened
i'd be fine
my girl made that with chicken strips oh
yeah you did
double broccoli couldn't stop farting oh
my gosh to the point where my
five-year-old son was like daddy i quit
farting it's hard it was time i was like
five you should enjoy the sick no it's
not fun me
gotta stop fighting like a boring dude
it was tough no more
i know we did we did that rotisserie
chicken and broccoli
hey look it was so funny because the
waiter kept asking y'all questions like
you want you usually no i want something
different he's like
i want a rotisserie chicken you sure
yeah yeah yeah
you want something you want some hot
sauce what the [ __ ] man
get my [ __ ] chicken or veggies like
broccoli nah you don't want to
[ __ ] up with uh tiger he's in it's
it's dope
he's into like uh earlier i'm sorry
late 80s and early 90s [ __ ] so like
rugrats
oh yeah yuck he's into doug he's in like
animaniacs
he's into um what's the other thing you
watching
uh
so i was like oh you like 80 [ __ ] i was
like when i was a kid i watched uh
little monsters have you ever seen
little monsters savage
wait oh that movie the movie oh yeah
yeah yeah have you seen a chin or cat
so yeah i haven't seen it but yeah
ben savage is in it too yeah but the and
the the
the ghost or i'm sorry the the monster
is uh
homeboy is boy he's a comic yeah that's
his brother
howie mandel right howie mandel is the
monster how he may nails that monster
yeah
how people forget how much of a beast
how's it go
see that's the problem bobby's world
dude howie mandel as far as comics goes
at the comedy store you're talking about
a
stir used to be a monster so now kids
are like oh the guy from
you know the [ __ ] game shows and all
that
monster dude used to be a monster
comedian yeah he had a lot of guys
running for
competing a lot of people oh dude did
you ever watch bobby's world that was
his show
and i didn't watch it yeah he oh yeah
created bobby and he did the character
for the box of little homie on the
bicycle super sad yeah
i didn't know i remember that [ __ ] was
dope
but uh so i showed my son little
monsters thinking you think it was dope
that's hard
he was [ __ ] terrified really
terrified longest night ever
because in that movie like the the
monster in that uh howie mandel
he's like a funny goofy monster uh-huh
he's such a colorful monster
i know but the world under the look at
his teeth and then he grows horns
yeah under the bed he's all scared
that scared the [ __ ] out of my son like
he pops out of the bed yeah he creeps
around at night
little terminator he scared the [ __ ] out
of him i wonder i wonder if they do
do it like that still i don't i don't
know any kids shows now or kid movies
but
and then there's the yeah the monsters
were different back in the day but these
are playful [ __ ] monsters
yeah they're pretty scary man when
you're really going
don't show them gremlins then don't
don't love grandma yeah
remember what about are you afraid of uh
the dart remember that tv show yeah
that was on yesterday that was hard yeah
little monster i [ __ ] up you [ __ ]
but then i told him like dude that
goes like higher man don't in real life
you know he won't shake hands
he won't grab handles you see him you
just give you knuckles
he's scared of germs yeah put your hands
up
you'll freak him out so he had to sleep
with the lights on i [ __ ] up damn i
[ __ ] up
you [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up how did it but
it is a dope movie it's good
it's it's so underrated but it hasn't
stayed with that time yeah
now now goosebumps is everlasting uh
but i read the books i read the books
and stuff but i don't know i don't know
if i ever
watched goosebumps with jack black right
yeah there we go don't say everlasting
because it's two years old but i hear
you
wait they made a movie out of it they
made it jack black i did not know that
yeah it's a good move i freaking love
joking didn't they re uh
he's so dope yeah he's hard i like that
you're right oh dude how
have uh have you seen i'm sure on social
media that's going around on
all the first take and all that [ __ ]
that they're saying now tom brady since
he's won seven rings
they're saying is he the greatest
athlete of all time what are you saying
i i have a lot to say about that go
ahead bernie
what are you going to say go ahead oh
absolutely not you can't say lebron
i'm not going to say lebron i'm the best
are you going to say you talking about
athlete
of all time of all time okay you please
let me see where he's got it
serena williams this i oh my i can't
believe
everyone's saying that everyone's saying
they're not saying it not the dummies
they're saying here's the problem with
serena williams
think about let's go let's go through
this i can't believe that's your take
that's so terrible what how how many how
many
females play tennis
growing up or just like just in general
expensive sport it is
how many people play it let's just say
like not many like no no no not that
many at all
right yeah so she dominates in that you
know the 200th
male tennis player beat the [ __ ] out of
her in tennis beat the [ __ ] up those are
early that was her uh
doesn't matter doesn't matter okay okay
she's even set on record i can't compete
with men
take gender out of it men women best
athlete serena williams isn't even the
[ __ ] compliment what do you have uh
you you could go tom it depends because
we're talking team sport i go tom brady
if you're talking maybe because it boils
down to
football's only in united states exactly
so how but but
everybody in the united states plays it
and it's so competitive and also
injury and then you look at the salary
cap in the nfl he's won
seven super bowls he's been to 10.
that's hard yeah max kellerman said if
you just take his last
five years 37 on yeah which is nuts as a
nfl player
37 on to now the last five years he's
still a first ballot hall of famer
correct
after 37. so football is a very north
american thing
so if we open up worldwide and talk
about greatest athlete of all time
you probably have to put soccer in there
everybody plays soccer you'd have to put
soccer or
fighting in there what about yeah what i
was gonna say what about floyd
mayweather he's up there he was behind
serena
to me that that's a really insane dude
serena's not in the conversation
you don't think so who's the best girl
she beat what are you talking about she
beat maria uh
yeah what's your name real famous
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's ten of them
there's ten i didn't know that i didn't
know that one tennis hold on so okay
let's just go so if you're talking about
individual sport
i mean and the thing about this usain
bolt so everyone runs
usain bolt everyone knows how to run so
everyone runs hussein bolt
and then there's michael phelps swimming
dominated but not everyone swims
okay i got you but everyone runs but
everyone's everyone knows how to fight
though everyone wants to be a fighter i
think how many fighters are
that's what i'm saying anyway think of
the competition
floyd had to go through through when he
was a kid
to golden gloves to olympics to
professional 15-0
the level of competition at that weight
class it's the most
comfortable it's so skillful and he's
fit you know
i got you serena williams the two hunt
the 300th guy would beat the [ __ ] out of
her for instance
our our uh us women's soccer team okay
dominate it's not even worth watching
the games they beat some teams 10 to
zero
okay a high school all-star team beat
the [ __ ] out of a men's
a boys high school all women are it's
not a gender thing we're talking about
greatest athlete
she might be the greatest female athlete
great when you're talking about overall
she's not even in the top 50. yeah
you're right
i guess i literally thought you were
going to say floyd mayweather not
because now
that's your taste why because you i mean
i know right i know right now
hollywood's woke in l.a
serena number one you're out of your
mouth
they had like a lot of like if it's
twitter everybody's stupid on twitter
because i woke up and i saw that i was
like serena and i saw lagoon so you just
joking i was like you know what she they
do they made a lot of great points
though
i'll well wrecked their points because
again think how expensive is to place to
play tennis as a kid yeah right
yeah and then how many women compete in
it not many
okay you dominating that cool all right
but also you gotta look at wayne gretzky
you gotta look at ronaldo and messi
you know get pele you got there's like
thinking my people play soccer
worldwide now think of all those people
that play soccer
how many make it to the premier league
which is the highest of highs
yeah not many now those guys dominate in
the premier league think how hard that
is that's hard
compared to tennis there's ten chicks
dude
you're not [ __ ] running you're not
even the running
soccer is a lot on the run yeah if think
i think how many [ __ ]
all over the world brazil china
everywhere asia russia
uh [ __ ] europe australia north
america everybody plays soccer and
ronaldo and messi
dominate okay i don't know all the
people are not always yours
so i they there's debate there ronaldo
messi pele there's
there's debate there okay as far as team
sport goes and then but but then
the argument for brady is he didn't play
defense
that's the only yeah but that's whatever
the thing with that nearest ronaldo
they're
attackers right but the thing is the
soccer you know but the thing is with
that
is uh with tom yeah learn sports so uh
the thing with that
left wing when i play soccer yep so with
uh brady
you gotta realize uh national football
league biggest league in the world right
there's nba but nfl
most most money maker every uh north
american kid
grows up want to be a football player
brady
not only seven uh world champions
been there ten times dominated right
yeah but then also
there's a salary cap in the nfl so
they're they're they're
controlled they're controlled and you're
your level of difficulty with the with
the minds of the defense coordinators
and injury the chance of injury is so
much higher i love how you
serena williams rolls her ankles let's
just throw her throw sereno away throw
her away that's so stupid okay
if you wanna i know it's that cool thing
to say right yeah dude and i love her
she dominates in women's tennis
she's not in the [ __ ] conversation
she was trendy i was like what's and
they said the greatest athlete yeah
because it's the woke thing to do right
yeah
it's not the she's not even in the
running break okay okay you're right
you're my bad [ __ ] you twitter
look at floyd mayweather though no no no
i think i literally thought you were
gonna say i was
praying he was safely not i thought you
believe it i was gone yes i know you're
on social media too much
yeah exactly someone told me serena and
i laughed in their face and i was like
that's actually trending like i'm like
no
no one knows what the [ __ ] they're
talking about yeah if you if i didn't
see that this morning and see her
twitter because they had like great
points
just just go through the odds of making
it to the professional level the hardest
sport to go professional in is baseball
i don't know what it is in premier
league but as far as north america
the chances to make it the hardest at
like the
major leagues there's triple a double a
single a the hard skill pro is baseball
wait minor so you gotta go to minor
league first do you know you a college
triple h minors yeah or you can just go
college and go straight to the pros
which a lot of guys do
where some guys go high school to the
pros but they
you're not going to get a lot of playing
time yeah i don't know i don't know but
but but the point is is that uh baseball
is the most
you that's statistically hurt the last i
heard is the hardest scope
like major major leagues in because
there's so many different leagues it's
hard to make it out but we're talking
about athlete and the most athletic
person i've seen in my lifetime
nope lebron james we're not talking
we're not saying who's the best athlete
because there's guys who don't score any
baskets in the nba who are on the bench
which is insanely athletic
okay there's fighters i've seen who are
the best guys ever in the training room
but they don't
it doesn't it doesn't count they don't
trade it doesn't matter what do you what
are you doing
athletic okay so lebron has a 40 inch
vertical
so did so did jordan he's shorter and
then also hussein bolt runs a [ __ ]
three seven in the 40. lebron can't do
that so you sound
you saying bo is up there where's your
time let me see your top three let me
just hear it
i'd be brady okay jordan gretzky ronaldo
messi
like it's just it's just tough because
again if we take in
level of difficulty to what floyd's done
yeah
he has to be in those top five oh yeah
you're talking about boxing
talking about injury concussions the
level of competition he's fighting the
best of the best
50 and oh dude right 50 you know him
yeah
and but then also well if we're talking
about that then you're throwing the
heavyweight division
you're throwing heavyweights talking
about george foreman frazier muhammad
ali
because think of the level dfl at
heavyweight and during that time
dog yeah all right and then heavyweights
they get [ __ ]
up that's such an art that's such a
debatable question like again
serena's not yeah i saw her serena's
only reason why because you'd have to
toss in pete sampras
agassi you'd have tossed in the mail
everyone you you know what pizza
serena williams wouldn't touch the ball
if pete sampras was in his prime when
they played
wouldn't touch she would get annihilated
and that's not a saria williams prom
that's a male to female problem
okay what about tiger was tiger up there
that's golf
dominant but he did he's not better than
uh homeboy the
the golden bear who's who he's chasing
jack nicholson no not i mean i said jack
uh no i hear you who is it uh uh no wait
is that
what's the guy that is jack uh the
golden bear
the girl who's chasing for the most
green jackets he he
he's like seven he has like 18 or
something like that yeah he's chasing
him
i i think tiger could have been
considered jack nicholas jack nicholas
that's who he's chasing yeah so you're
saying he's not
and then michael schumacher and you know
we're talking about f1 it's like
it's tough dude we're just athletes it's
tough
damn that's such a debatable question
you're right when i saw serena trending
and it was making people just woke i was
woke i was walking black female
black females real hot right now that's
hot in the news
but when you take out your biased
opinions she's not
even the top 100 dude well hold on i
wouldn't give her that it's on top 100.
there's not enough there's not enough
sample size you okay so you're dominate
over
30 women who play tennis is she the best
woman in tennis we can 100
okay so she congrats she's in the top
one honey no not even close
if the 200th man can beat your ass in
tennis
and we're talking about straight up best
athlete and the 200th men in your sport
can beat you
and we're just talking about athletics
and serena prime and you saying the 200
guy who
she wouldn't touch the ball dude they've
played they played yeah a guy beat the
brakes off him
our national team a high school all-star
team
beat the [ __ ] out of them a high school
team you know me those kids will to the
premier league
zero you know me will play on the
national team zero
beat the [ __ ] out of her you're right
all right i want you
but but i don't know why i don't know
how she got i i bro you saw that right
i'm not tripping she was true oh no
someone brought up to me at starbucks
we're talking about him like
what and he's like you know it's
ridiculous like that's trending yeah
that's insane i saw that yeah but they
made great points but then
if you take the bias and walk out of it
yeah it has what's hot right now
cancel culture i like how you said
global global is soccer
and fighting so i get what you're saying
but soccer fighting running
i would say basketball because you play
basketball everywhere oh yeah yeah you
play basketball so that's why lebron
yeah
you play basketball but so you wouldn't
put lebron
up there no really the hell he's lost
two minutes compared to tom he's been
there ten times
and how many has he lost you just talked
about salary how many has he lost
and the salary cap in the nba is
completely different than
nfl yeah but he had bums and scrubs we
know he had brady had good teams
yes he had a coach bro lebron never had
oh yeah how's this coach doing without
him
he ain't [ __ ] how many different coaches
has lebron had and what he never had a
coach he never had a great
coach like belichick you he can't be in
it he's not even the best in his sport
what wait what whoa whoa whoa of all
time we're
we're talking all time he's not better
he's not better than jordan dude
okay i don't even want to get started on
that but if like if and that's debatable
because
not really like the the jordan debate's
pretty
pretty solid so if you're not even the
best of your time you're not in this
conversation
so it's like you know wrong name a
better uh
michael phelps
name a better quarterback than tom brady
none he dominated
name a better soccer player than messi
none i guess you say ronaldo
they play together that's debatable they
play i'm not
floyd mayweather's retired he's fighting
[ __ ] you know youtubers
he doesn't count i'm talking about his
boxing resume
yeah yeah yeah muhammad ali george
foreman for asia like there's all
there's different guys formidable
mayweather was literally my first
thought
yeah just think about the level of
competition because it took something to
get to 50 and
it was insane his level of difficulty to
get to 15 year old computer this arena
you're right yeah i think how many guys
want to be floyd mayweather and tried to
take that crown
and he beat him yeah
when you when you go into the boxing gym
think how many guys can fight at floyd
mayweather's weight
a [ __ ] all of them everybody has the
deepest division especially when he was
coming up
and he excelled in that right i'm sorry
dejuan i know you're watching apologize
tell floyd i'm good
no i know what you're saying though uh
floyd soccer players
fighters and running i get that but
basketball is up there and
the fact you said lebron that's that's
crazy but i like your top three
but i had to switch eggo floyd lebron
and i didn't really watch too much
soccer so i said you saying both and
then i have my him or michael phelps
you can that's fine if he thought
if he thought serena in there that's
interesting
i know but people don't know [ __ ] and
it's the hot thing to do
okay yeah oh serena number one girl
power
i get that best female sure they have
that conversation on the side
we're talking about the best straight up
best athletes what about uh
she wouldn't touch the ball against the
200th guy wouldn't
touch the [ __ ] would it be a game
yeah you see yeah
sure that's that's what you're going to
bring to the table she won this and i
get
against all the females let her play a
male see what happens
right i wouldn't we don't do that in any
other sport no other sport
they do the mixing tennis the mix tennis
now i mean you talk about doubles
yeah yeah whatever i'm talking i'm
talking about we like just
we don't compare any like marion jones
compared to same ball dude
a high school track runner in the 100
yard dash
destroys our olympic gold medal winner
in the world
a high school track today would destroy
the olympic gold medal women sprinter
female so it's just i don't know why how
women got involved in this
i don't know and i'm not saying they're
not great athletes i don't i think they
should be
saying we have the separated like best
male athletes the best our best toss
them in there but they're not in the top
50. we saw
go ahead and toss them in there that's
fine but when you're talking about
[ __ ] performance level difficulties
and there's so much
that yeah how many guys play sports how
many women play sports
a lot yeah you're right yeah
[Music]
yeah you're right damn twitter dog no no
one said deion sanders no you know like
he again that's the bet he said the
greatest of your sport so if you you
think about football who do you think
off the rip who's the greatest of all
time
that's tom brady john elway what sorry i
like shout out to dude
he stopped no he's not oh what i just i
got i freaked out i was like
uh little dab
is the greatest of all time in your
sport in your category you're right
i should have yeah i should have known
from jordan i can't believe that was
your take well i said
it's so frustrating they bugged me on
that
you're on that hypebeast social media i
was on twitter it's not that's not
real no i know that's not real even
serena williams probably
she probably woke up trending like you
know what
they had great points and then you know
because so soon as you see something i'm
like
why is she trending what happened
something happened to her and they said
the greatest athlete of all time was
serena williams then they had like
a [ __ ] uh powerpoint they had like
examples
they had highlights i was watching the
highlights have two people sit down and
actually have that conversation
twitter it's easy yeah because anybody
could just go and just post post most of
those posts yeah but have like two
legit sports natural smart guys guys
like stephen a smith
like and have that conversation like if
smith and max
if that's their job yeah no dude like
you got to think like a conversation on
twitter is
not a real conversation and they have an
agenda steven they would have been mad
at you saying lebron james not in
like the top five he was like that's
completely asinine
he might it's just tough when jordan's
there you know
and we're talking about guys are you
talking about like because you're
talking about like bodybuilding
lebron the finals how many times
ten times lost six lost six he's for
shooting forty percent
in the finals go about doing number
eleven and about to do another he's five
and six i i think he'll get another uh
at least
yeah yeah yeah okay so he's on his way
but another one but still tom brady
seven out of ten
in football which is insane football
and he's 43 and that was his first year
with the bucks right yeah
they've never won before they went nine
and seven last year
nine and seven best team in the nfl this
year it ain't belichick
it's tom brady and he's 43.
he's not is he i respect yeah he's kind
of hard yeah he was lit at that [ __ ]
uh party dog
there uh we got off the boat yeah right
he was hit
that's how you know you had it so many
times
i had it every time i played yeah more
rings than any franchise right yes yeah
and it's not a sexist thing
it's when it it you're talking muscle to
performance
it's it's a absolute thing yeah not even
running people just wanna you're saying
people just want to be that's right
that's no different saying well mary and
jones is better than hussein balt
well let's look at their times oh wow
not even close
what's your argument yeah but she i
don't give a [ __ ] who has the best times
take out penis no penis who has the best
time okay
i'll take example a example b take out
female male
and you break take out all sacks and
just give me the best who's the best
women they're just not in there dude the
level of difficulty the
the sample size is nowhere near yeah and
i rest my kids lisa leslie no
brittany grinder just like take take
women out of sports completely
no no because she she's a beast in that
but when you're talking about all-time
great
yeah no matter what the sex they're not
in there
the sample size is not the same the
level difficulty is not the same
it's like saying uh uh all uh what's the
name lala
ali or closer shields or whatever
how many women fight not a lot now how
many men fight
so many [ __ ] so many yeah the level
difficulty is so much more harder for
men
you're right that's what they do okay
it's not a sex thing no
yeah just give me example a
example b let's take track yeah let's
take the state
soccer how many goals did pele score how
many goals did whoever you want to take
over here
well i'll take him oh but this is a girl
okay whatever i'll take
example eight so you don't think it's
impressive that lebron like
you know he may not have said he he may
not have gotten the rings the first year
with these teams like
when he went back to cleveland and you
know it took him the second
second round he was the greatest and
then like with the lakers
you know it took him two two tries to
get through everything that's like
listen it's impressive for sure
but there's a debate him or jordan right
true
so you lebron might be in your top five
but if you have lebron in there jordan's
in there
of all time greatest wait how many times
has jordan been in the finals six
how many has he won six there you go
what are we talking about bill russell
has more rings than jordan what is it
rings or athleticism what are we talking
about here
with jordan compared to lebron
athleticism oh oh
wait don't you do that don't you do that
that's you i don't know
more athletic than lebron james lebron
james
six nine can run like a six two one's
[ __ ] gifted
yo jumping out the gym for sure
everything and you telling you
so again i take all my bias out of it i
know example a
michael jordan and you read all his
accolades lebron
lebron has better accolades again
points who has more assists who has more
rebounds if we talk about production i
mean i mean
only thing he has is he's 6-0 in the
finals that's a big deal dude
he's right here do you think tom brady
is the most athletic quarterback
no no no he's not even close on the top
hunt not on top
1 000 quarterbacks of all time for
athleticism colin kaepernick's more
athletic
but then i look at horn he's been the
super brawl how many times he's won how
many times oh that yeah
i get what you're saying i get what
you're saying too you just said take
stuff out of it give me like okay look
at the stats give me that
give me that take dick take all that
take lebron james and you look at
just if i saw you a blank screen of
someone that's production
you'll go with lebron maybe maybe
okay all right well he's top five that's
completely
top five yeah but no it's all
i'm not saying he's not yeah that's fine
if he's on my athlete yeah
yeah that's fine okay that's fine okay
but you're good but if you have lebron
then you have to have jordan in there
there's gonna be after a 5a 5b
or you could put jordan fourth or six
but he's gonna have to be in there but
again how many people play basketball
it's a global thing now you know that's
what i'm saying
and it's more skillful guys today than i
say back then probably lebron sure he's
still dominating he's still the best
player on the planet yeah
all right that was that was yeah you're
right
i woke up
you see that you see that like who's the
greatest of all time and of course i'm
gonna go buy his floyd mayweather
and then they had like a whole floyd's
fine yeah floyd's a good pick
yeah but this men's box in that division
to be 50 and oh dude oh yeah and that in
the world
you know how skillful you have to be and
how many people
box at that weight class a [ __ ] ton a
lot how many people all around the world
box
olympics china so his website is popular
[ __ ] yeah yeah all the the smaller
weight classes are the most technical
most skilled people in the world
because because they're smaller so they
gravitate towards that sport
they can't play football they can't play
basketball they can't play baseball
they all go towards fighting if you're a
155 pound man
what sport you can play basketball get
the [ __ ] out of here you're too small
we're gonna play
we're gonna play football you're too
small when you play baseball boxing is
they go to fighting yeah so the sample
size there is massive dude yeah
and floyd mayweather dominated didn't
get hit sometimes
fresh out of prison still like
dominating the sport
i remember he was fresh out of prison
and he was sparring training for that
robert guerrero fight
and earl came but they had this other
guy this white guy in there
and he was like fresh out this is first
day spawn this white guy he's from um
from out here and floyd was like i don't
know what happened in the pen we didn't
question it but floyd kept poking him on
his butt
he was like you might you mind today i
was like okay floyd prison floyd you
chained man
ain't no guard driving are you gonna be
holding my pocket today
all right i'm not
i'm going to eat lunch at caesars after
this dude i'm not holding your [ __ ]
pocket bro you think you will [ __ ] we
broken up tonight
he's got a gym that's being built up on
vine did you see that yeah and he has
the one on one is that like
what like a it's a crossfit it's a
training oh it's not like a boxing gym
nah uh i used to uh tr well you should
train people out of that the one in
wilshire
well i don't know floyd has a gym off
well sure what's wrong uh
maybe uh i didn't know that yeah
mayweather boxing gym on western
and now he's building another one on uh
on uh vine
yeah that's what i'm saying that's a is
that a boxing gym he's building this
sounds like a little bit
another person you got tossed in there
it's a little different because
they have different uh cars we got toss
in uh lewis hamilton
how dominant he is and we talked about
it again if we're talking
of all time and you talk about sports f1
outside north america is [ __ ]
massive massive and lewis hampton
dominates on that
caveat with that is if you put my boy
danny ricardo in that same car he
probably dominates
more because in f1
like let's say we're all three racers
yeah you race for a mercedes i race for
mclaren you
you race for a renault my car is not as
powerful as yours
oh god that way so it's about your skill
driving
and that's why like danny ricardo is
considered
so what does hamilton drive mercedes and
dominates but he has the faster car than
the rest of them
so people were like well if danny
ricardo had that mercedes how would he
do
probably [ __ ] because because danny's
the g he's a yeah
more y'all told me how there's only what
20 that make it
20. yeah yeah but again sample size
when you're a kid coming up it's so
expensive to get started
so expensive
but then when you look at pure dominant
in their sport look at
wayne gretzky people forget are you dude
that's your guy
it's not even my guy i went on that one
tour
holy [ __ ] and i went back home and did
my research like that [ __ ]
dominated more than lebron jordan his
records will never be passed like you're
talking about not even close dude
who's the next one like sydney crosby i
heard or alex um
damn dominant but that's that's such a
va that question is so hard to choose
from
because you have so many people the
question's hard to choose from but
what's clear as day is surreal
[Laughter]
you woke up and you're wrong i'm like
all right brendan
i was up all night because i watched
that movie uh joe uh
judah and the black messiah did you just
come out of netflix
hbo max okay how is it you know it's a
it's long two hour movie uh you know
good movies need about two hours though
to get really develop the storylines
yeah
seriously malcolm x with denzel's what
like three three hours yeah
that's a great movie great movie don't
even oh honestly it was great um
it just shows you like how is it based
on the true story true story how fred
hampton
yeah died at the age of 21. um young
the guy this guy this danger he's a
british panther yeah he's a
black panther people are so scared of
the black panthers yo they too
i didn't know so kicks are sick there
are those dunks oh the directors and i
think those are
asics who directed it uh uh i don't know
who directed but i know ryan
japanese denim there all right all right
all right all right
he went to jail because the the police
lied to him about like him stealing like
some ice cream and he had to do three to
five right
and now he's gonna terrified like oh
people were they were scared yeah
wait the lucas brothers had something on
this yeah they were in there right
uh or i think they yeah i think they
might have one
probably produced it oh yeah you know
what i started to watch is the
the cecil hotel doc is on netflix it
came out last night
oh scared it is yeah [ __ ] yeah why the
[ __ ] are we going there
nightmares you had nightmares so you and
tiger had nightmares
yes yeah so when he was up i was like
i'm up too
now what did it what did they show you
that you didn't know
um i knew i i knew most of it but they
go into the backstory of that girl
yeah other girls her parents you know as
a father
her parents when she was 21 she was
always she would like
blog all her [ __ ] she's like going to
travel
and her parents are like cool just call
us every day you let a 21 year old
come to california she started san diego
then she went to i think santa barbara
and she stayed at the [ __ ] ciso hotel
downtown like do your research [ __ ]
yeah like the parents
dude it's not long ago
that was six years ago not long ago
oh yeah we went to 2000 and they don't
really uh
talk about her uh mental health issues
either 13
2013 2017 seven years ago i said six
i was off he was close but then yeah
dude
but yeah they uh this is this uh
um thing i watched on youtube they
really went deep into like her mental
health
and it wasn't really talked about on the
dot no not really see this weird that's
yeah that's what's strange and then then
jay sends me a doc
he's like hey fans are sending this
thing what you're bringing up on below
the belt
is basically how the irish mob runs
boxing and they're incorporated with
tyson fury
and all you know uh billy joe saunders
and this guy
started mgm boxing gym i'm in the
documentary
i told you hey i want no problem son
that's what they do that's what they do
yeah i love ireland i'm all in
i got my own whiskey coming out if you
guys want to help
i want hey man that's your [ __ ] overseas
you performed in ireland right
oh yeah dude top three of all time
dublin
remember that chin it was the best
what's the theater you went to dublin
yeah something sugar factory
should be like a small like little
theater i got that oh really it was dope
dude i did a show in the afternoon i did
a show at two in the afternoon on a
wednesday
i did it two four six and eight and all
in one day [ __ ] four shows one day
damn
lit as [ __ ] oh you you uh
documented it yeah it was awesome oh
that looks [ __ ] amazing all
intimate and [ __ ] i like that jacket
that's what he had that hair cut boy
right after that so what are you
bringing in for congress
[ __ ] them up
what year was this be 2017. four years
ago four years ago
damn was that's how you've been there
four years
oh that was the last time this is video
oh you were supposed to go
look at this oh it is kind of hard i'll
see you chin
did all this no no they did it remember
[Music]
dude were getting lit it was so what's
up ireland
and then we just go they had me pull the
guinness
i kept the guests in the back look at
chad
i got a 49-0 shirt on because that's
when floyd
oh dope it was so awesome
there's people sitting down in the
aisles
that's oh that's that's amazing wait
what did you say
what did you just say what did you say
look at me pulling that guinness that
[ __ ] was fantastic all day every day and
then oh
my god i used to go harder i got it lit
on guinness i came out the show just
faded as [ __ ]
patty hooligan remember he came here we
are in the uk
yeah that [ __ ] looked fun well we had we
were supposed to go back this year but
kovitz was like nah i got different
plans for you oh [ __ ]
i want to go uk so [ __ ] bad dude man
likewise
we'll be out there next man probably
next year next year
yeah we're gonna i i think we're in
postponting next year
they might do it we got matching tattoos
uh-huh oh everyone i need to go there i
need to go to the uk
what tattoo oh youngster
yeah oh okay look at china whole
different person i know dude
time i think it's mainly just so you got
some good hair look at jade
jay looks different did you know when
you're in the heart that's why i tattoo
artists
he was like he was like you're not gonna
you got really good hair bruh i did it
britney was in shape
just do the goddamn nap
it was so intense i can't believe you
wanted it on your neck i was down
yeah he wouldn't do it on that's your
first time your first tattoo yeah that's
why
[Music]
i don't know you know how like uh all
access uh 24 7. what about the fight
they did a great job i think paul jobs
he just he's great
yeah i've never been i've never been uh
to the uk or anything
that shirt i was wearing was the barber
out there remember that barber
cut your hair yeah you kept my hair
how many seats is that like 400 yeah
400.
what are you watching here we're good
yeah godzilla please reminisce actually
yeah that [ __ ] felt good
yeah it did it had to be was that was
that your first tour in
the uk oh yeah damn first and only you
went
so you did ireland then you went to no
we did we no
dublin was the last of it right i think
so yeah we start out with uh uk
england first or something like that in
london we did cardiff there's patty
manchester you didn't manchester there's
patty
man they did manchester what's your
manchester accent look like what did
i actually don't know how they how their
accent is
uh and i don't want to do it because i
don't want to embarrass myself oh asus
is from
oasis the smiths stone roses
a lot of greats out of uh manchester
i've done so many you heard again
i've done so many shows i forget a lot
about it thank god that's documented
yeah
is it is it better than this we're at
the look at j's jersey
here we're at i think the oldest bar in
uh dublin yeah from the civil war in
dublin they had
still bullet holes in the front of it
and the bricks and
wait as soon as you walk in you can see
it yeah you see the bullet hole those
buildings are like
out there i don't know what it is 17
something you you do scotland
no we when we go back out we're doing
scotland we're doing north ireland we're
doing dublin
yeah we had a whole it was like it was
it was ireland
sweden forget where else we had a big
ass you've been to sweden
no i was supposed to suppose i don't
think so playboy
sweden i'd love to go there too they
have a great punk scene out there
sweden does yeah i heard it's dope yeah
it's crazy to me when uh my agent's like
yeah we're gonna line up sweden i'm like
who the [ __ ] listens to me in sweden and
then you see the ticket sales like are
you serious yeah
are you ready like they're just going to
get all the references because they
listen to the podcast
no no like all american references so i
was like man minecraft's gonna change my
act do this like no
they get don't change anything they get
all of it man no i'm talking about like
okay so like
with with your agent they're like uh are
they just rolling the dice on like yes
no we have
we also have analytics reports too so i
send them reports about like
who's the majority of listeners isn't
that so they're just kind of gone
so obviously north america number one
yeah should break down a city in north
america but it's crazy how much
in uh new york are like in texas yeah
the biggest markets and then it's the uk
australia uk
yeah they're huge yeah dude there's so
many listeners over there it's insane
you know how many dm's i get with mike
mike you know me and chen uh toured
australia together yeah
yeah it was just just we barely knew
each other it was kind of awkward
because i just
joined the company how long ago was this
same same time frame wait j when jay
wasn't with you
she was there i don't know yeah that's
right what's going on
it's just you and me yeah
that's when i learned about different
asians because there's so many asians in
australia
i'm like well these chinese people
cheney like dude those are japanese
and then i was like look at all these
japanese like dude those are korean
is there a specific reason why so many
asians go to australia
it's their vegas like when they're on
holiday because it's close for them to
get there they just come on down
a lot of them live there too and
australia is like america
but cleaner better looking people and
just like
like super polite great so nice we did
math it was great
we did massive we did straight up
massive theaters
massive theater humongous headlining
first time in australia
how long was that flight it's a long
like 17 16 hours
that's crazy i got people's in
queensland but it's fun though because
i had like like my own little hotel room
we flew like jetblue or something
so jetblue mint so i was laying down i
fell asleep for like 10 hours
they give you food it was dope i watched
all these movies
it was fun that's a long ass flight yeah
the 17 hour i mean
it's like i can barely handle from
[ __ ] florida but you lay out you lay
out when you
know it's like that you're you have a
different mentality like
florida is just a beast again like six
hours like [ __ ]
but then also you gotta fly back in
three or four days
like australia i know i was there for
like a week or week and a half so
it's not that just
we got off the plane and then went to go
see kangaroos
kangaroos and koalas how big are those
like uh it came
it was a weird setup because the
kangaroos were like all this like
you know they're all drugged out they
were drunk they were drugged out they
were all nightclub
really yeah because they wanted to be
chilly because they they're constantly
feeding them yeah everyone just buy
something
i'm happy yeah they're like scratching
their bellies
real life kangaroo bro cool have me
laying down next to them
yeah now me and chin are holding koalas
the koalas are chill huh yeah their
nails are long like dig into your shirt
oh got it but they're slow they're like
eating leaves eucalyptus leaves non-stop
they're all just eaten
it's cool oh squeezing their nose i
don't know if i want to pick that animal
though
no they're cool yeah i can't grab the
animals noses i kept grabbing their nose
like dude you gotta quit squeezing the
face
what is it here no i don't know no i
don't know i like that animal alone i
said i liked it i liked it
yeah i don't need you i don't need to be
picking up animals like that you do you
i don't even like to [ __ ] pick up
cats do you go to a zoo [ __ ] no
we got some jay got some email for when
we're in tampa some florida zoo they're
like yeah we have tigers and panthers
brendan can [ __ ] around with oh my
britney can [ __ ] around yeah [ __ ]
i mean i do but you went to that kind of
stuff though
i'd be down i i like watching it oh
i have like these pictures all the way
back in my albums but yeah and then this
is a great one here uh
those customized shoes right there it
says those are gucci they say love
i think your love is tight does it
really yeah it says love
something love drunk love tight love
drunk in love
oh look at me look at me oliver oh my
god look at that
they're so chill dude that's kangaroo
black right there
got it hey is he asleep what is he doing
he's he's he's drugged up so they just
so they drug him up for the people
so like i mean it's just they're drugged
or they're just like so like content
because
they're fed they're just constantly
being fed people want to buy stuff just
to get near them so they always buy the
food and they come up and feed them so
there's like oh another bite
you eat and just lay down yeah i don't
trust it you don't trust them they're
cool
yeah i i get i don't yeah because i like
an
animal can think whatever the [ __ ] they
want they'd be like [ __ ] i don't
like you how you scared of animals but
you watch that little animals killing
each other all the time
i'm watching it i'm watching what do you
want from a distance
i follow uh nature's metal oh yeah and i
watch all that [ __ ]
the dark side of nature cause i think
it's i just think i don't know why i
just think it's so unique nature's
success
is [ __ ] i mean like that is savage
with that that's how they got to eat
they get you know they have they have to
like literally hunt their [ __ ] food
like me and tiger on a hike the other
day and there's a big ass hawk and then
there's like little like
basically pigeons flying over it and the
hawk was like chasing them he's like why
are they chase each other like
because that big one's trying to eat
those little yeah they're more little
ones hungry flying for his life
yeah he's like yeah man he's like then
why did mice like
because we'll see like mice and stuff or
yeah blizzard she's like why are they
hide all the time run away i'm like
because they're hiding from that big ass
hock
because the vision to see them and they
[ __ ] eat them you'll see them like
swoop up a fish
yeah yeah they're claw yeah have you
ever seen the eagles like grab the goats
off the mountain and just pick them up
oh they're like drop them and then
look at him picking up lebron yeah i
like all that stuff i like watching
lions [ __ ] hunt
that's like my favorite oh you know
what's funny about lebron lebron's so
thirsty in the goat conversation he's
like jumping on the tom brady stuff
like any time tom post something like
damn you crazy dog
man everyone's all chill out
he's shallow thirsty get in no
meanwhile michael's like this with
sitting on billions of dollars from his
shoes like
i took that personally you know what's
so funny about tom brady's instagram
his story he was putting in like yo he
was talking [ __ ] he had like pictures of
his team in his squad playing number rap
songs
oh really he was playing drake we made
it he played
he played trophies bro tom brady is so
funny no i love him you're so happy you
see uh
you ever met him i've never met tom
brady no i've seen him one time you've
seen him one time i've never seen him
never met him
you're all right lebron nah i seen him
sitting down at his hotel when he sits
down he's about right here he's [ __ ]
man he's
talking yeah yeah huge six nine right he
had to hold me back
huh he's six nine i think yeah he's six
nines every bit of it yeah
monster monster you don't realize how
big those basketball players are do you
seem like i saw carmelo anthony in
person i'm like
well you're a giant sure you're a giant
yeah
so that's how i felt when i saw draymond
green i didn't think draymond green was
that
that tall and then i trained right next
to him i did some work with draymond
he's thin
man i can't believe how because he looks
kind of big oh yeah he looks big on the
basketball field
yeah i was on facetime with him i've
never seen uh
real he's thinking what are you six four
so draymond was like i was surprised how
small draymond was what are you six two
yeah 16.
lucky yeah and draymond was thin man but
then you
you know matt barnes always around here
him and staff oh yeah he's [ __ ]
they're so
huge and again they're not considered
big in the nba
when you see carmelo like what the [ __ ]
and his handles and [ __ ] like holy [ __ ]
he's a big guy how tall is kyrie kyrie's
like what six
three six four six three yeah oh really
yeah
oh but you can't trust that and then you
look at then they lie
they lie so he's probably six one yeah
and then you look at uh like
uh kevin durant he's basically seven
foot and the skills he has you're like
jesus christ
like a kyrie or then think you think
durant's better than lebron huh yeah
skill wise and then you think of like uh
stefan uh
curry steph yeah steph curry yeah
wardell and think how small he is
getting shots off against guys like
kevin durant oh my god
how do you do it i hate steph curry i
used to hate on him but he's like the
most exciting player
to watch right now he's killing right
now really oh my god he's super baller
bro he makes the game look so fun
because he throws up shots
he posted he still he still got that he
ball he did uh he does those trick shots
before the game he did one the other
night like an underhand trick shot oh
when he threw it up like that
a half court you know who does that uh
trey young
he's a beast at that
curry just yeah what is it shot
that one it was just like whatever
yeah we already won
like that's nuts dude hey uh type in
trey young's uh
uh trick shot before the game and he's a
beast oh my god so it's just so
small bro he's just like think about
them going to the lane
how do they how they get shots they're
so elusive they're so quick yeah they
use their body yeah yeah but shreem
williams better yeah
treyarch from the [ __ ] there it is uh
from the bench this one
uh this one no that's 2019 no he did it
a couple of days ago this one's
impressive though
his hair is not impressive go back
change
there you go he looks like a weird he's
a weird yeah he's aware of you right
what's this
super baller i don't know gosh yeah oh
god
he can play some ball uh i think he's
like from the bench yeah from the bench
and it was like a migos song he waited
to like drop it was like splash
five days ago oh right here right here
amigos you see it
go back yeah yeah go back one see
is this when lebron got in that argument
with that lady trey young time this this
one yeah yeah
look at this did it on cue and it said
splash
give some value gin it's a migos all
right yeah
you can't really
he did
yeah how about jj watt out of here out
of houston yeah he's done
he's done he retired he no he wanted to
go he asked for he has to be released
and houston released him
oh they did houston's a [ __ ] show man so
there's something going on there
they don't why they want they don't want
to talk about there's something going on
that we don't know about
it must be so toxic for [ __ ]
you know he's the face of the
organization he's the most famous
houston texan of all time for him to be
like hey i need out
and then they say he wants to go play
with his brothers they both play for
pittsburgh yeah his
little brother i think it's tj yeah
should have been
defensive player of the year such a
baller oh really his brother
he got robbed he's better than him
really of course yeah
so but his so that's joe and his other
brother's a fullback they both
play for pittsburgh he wants to play
with his brother because they're real
close
but pittsburgh doesn't have the cap
space so unless he takes a pay cut
they're not gonna i think he
i think he'll probably take one but he
probably wouldn't yeah because ben
is uh taking one but free desean watson
like
look he's been asking for it there's
something going on and
that they're not telling us because
everyone wants to get the [ __ ] out of
there
yeah something's going on there oh [ __ ]
this is this weekend
yeah we spent burns oh yeah ufc 258 who
you
i got camaro i don't like the disrespect
people are giving him like he's so
good mm-hmm he's so good for whatever
reason he just
i don't know he's like a stipe where he
just doesn't get the respect he deserves
he's so [ __ ] good him and burns you
speak teammates real close they did
real close i didn't know that i go so
far back with burns he was just a jiu
jitsu coach when i was trained in
florida
not even fighting yet was just how long
how long was the world championship
guy [ __ ] eight nine years ago no you
damn
you looking at the points uh the spread
when you get the crib though cook a
healthy meal watch the fights cooking
healthy we're cooking them wings what
y'all doing for dollar pads
legit they're so good my girls it was
the lemon peppers
the lemon pepper man
wing restaurant we waited two hours for
some pizza but i didn't give a damn
because the wings were waiting
it kept you steady kept you great dude
are you guys doing anything for
valentine's day i'm going to santa
barbara i think yeah
you're taking a girl santa barbara yes
what are you guys doing just chilling in
the hotel she's been working on this
shoot for a long time so we just wanted
to
get out there on saturday uh when we
leave food finish here and then friday
and saturday come back sunday i forgot
today's friday you get
you getting her a gift yeah i'm gonna
get a little something yeah
we're gonna get a little jury some jury
some jury
you know every kid gets a jury what are
you gonna do my girl we're just chilling
out the crib yeah
because white white mike's out of town
whatever so where's white mike
uh no he's in phoenix this weekend
perfect house of comedy
if y'all wanna go see white mike mike in
phoenix at a house of comedy yeah
they're all we
like the mic yeah go see the white the
white one
uh you're the first person to ever call
him that that's insane it's insane
now that i think of it i'm like that's
why really it just means yeah i like
poking white guy in the hood yeah
well you know white mike you know white
mike
white mike
everybody got a white mic in the hood
everybody everybody got a white
and white kid yeah what you doing for
valentine's day yeah what you doing
uh we have the fights on saturday and
then i'll give my girl some dude she'll
watch him with you
oh she loves fighting oh hell yeah he
loves them it should be canelo
huge they're from the same uh hood uh oh
[ __ ] huge canelo fan
drives me nuts same age too huh similar
yeah yeah
yeah you're right oh wait we came up
together but um
wait a minute yeah i think so anyway um
yo do that chill have the fights have
some
healthy stuff
it's tough it's time she got me for
valentine's day she gave it to me
yesterday she got me athletic clothes
to keep me focused okay that's cute hey
it's always nice when you get some
athletic clothes that's what i got her
though yeah
so we both got each other athletic
clothes that's what's up she's down
seven pounds it's a gift exchange
i got these nike shorts from like 2012.
i need to get some new ones
i just don't know what the style is for
uh athletics that's what i had to do
i did like i don't know i don't
understand my girl went to under armour
and she's like get what you want for
valentine's day it was like say less
and i got a bunt bunch of [ __ ] yeah i
got this hoodie there i got a bunch [ __ ]
what kind of shirt you get like high
shorts you gotta have but you gotta have
compressions
under them compression you don't have to
but i like shorts i like the children
you see my shorts
yeah you saw my favorite god nba for
short shorts
yeah nuts have hung out the front yeah
yeah yeah yeah what are you doing for
valentine's day
um i'm actually coming back on
valentine's day after this i'm leaving
going to san jose for um chinese new
year and then
i come back on sunday i think we're just
gonna have dinner and hang out
chinese new year you're not chinese
though uh well chinese doing your
vietnamese new year fall on the same day
it just makes more sense to say chinese
new year than say thut because you guys
wouldn't know what thought is
[ __ ] you could have yeah yeah yeah yeah
what are you doing
so what do you guys do you guys have a
big party uh yeah usually we would have
a big party everybody
gives out red envelopes and you give
like a dollar to in there it's basically
as
like a good luck it's not about the
monetary amount that you get it's more
of a
like hey this is my good luck to you for
this uh new year coming up
you go and then you for like a week or
three days depending on how long your
family likes to celebrate you gamble
you gamble you drink you party you have
fun with your family is your finance
sister going to
yep she's there right now she left on
thursday oh right
mm-hmm you should have brought stevie up
there educate his ass
right i should he's just going to chill
down is your family aware of uh
you have a boyfriend oh yeah they all
know and you didn't want to bring him
huh uh i didn't even really think about
it honestly
because i didn't well i don't really
bring like significant others around my
family until
like a lot of time has passed like
saying
i'm just very like i don't like bringing
people around my family unless i know
like they're there to stay
like i don't [ __ ] around with stuff like
that and you don't think stevie's there
well i've
i haven't even been with him for a year
like my mom knows him my dad knows him
like i haven't met facetime
but yeah haven't like met in person yeah
just one of those things too i don't
think my parents are necessarily ready i
don't want to push them to like meet my
new boyfriend
if they're gonna like meet him then not
like him because they're not ready to
like be like oh my first kid i hear that
he's white
no they don't care that he's white they
only care if like he treats me well you
know
right now brendan do they give a [ __ ]
that he's white
a little bit right like oh [ __ ] no oh i
thought
well she's like a huge issue they don't
even care if he's like
uh other asians they just want him to
potentially be able to speak vietnamese
but like i've never dated a vietnamese
guy so
they're always like if he can hang with
the family it's fine as long as he
doesn't take himself seriously
what are you gonna do um well it's also
currently here too so i think
we based a lot of uh chinese new year so
today i'm gonna be with my girlfriend's
family doing the envelope stuff as well
i'm doing like 200 bucks with their
dollars i think hell yeah and then
tomorrow my girlfriend and i are just
gonna have like a we're gonna get a lot
of seafood live seafood and start
cooking together
live seafood live fish market you get
like live crabs
live shrimp all that stuff we're gonna
make a big ol seafood dinner oh that
sounds
nice oh so boiling crab sounds good i
know that you said that
can't touch it yeah
yeah right here um yeah chinese new
year's popping up you see all the
collabs nike is doing for chinese yeah
yeah i'm surprised you don't get those
cat i haven't seen them
dunks what they look like chinese new
york dunks
the chinese new year uh air maxes are
tough to get but
usually what a bunch of people in the
bay get is um the warriors always has
like a chinese new year
jersey that comes out oh yeah that's
usually what people caught their dogs
see there's
the top ones there's three there's three
so there's four if you include the nikes
the one that's not for cats are the real
asian ones see the red with a little
tassel on it right there
yes oh real dope i'll get you those cat
where do you get those
i'll get you those yeah what size shoe
do you wear uh six and a half
all your guys are like six and a half
brenden like
get it right get it right
and then there's those two both of those
the ones on the right are fine i didn't
know nike came out with chinese new
year's
smart they always come out with dunks
and they also come out with uh
valentine's day one this year's they did
here get that flexible leg up there
brother
that cat that hamster i got you all
right
i knew something was going on because i
heard it like
they did uh okay 703. okay we'll see cat
it's okay i got free money i'll get them
oh that's right you have money now yeah
yeah i forgot i don't have to buy hey
what what's the difference what's
goat like in comparison to stockx just
two different ones yeah two different
the same thing same thing i like goats
they move a little faster yeah but like
if i go to go and they don't have sizes
then i go to stockx you start stockx
they take a little long man you're
looking at two weeks
two weeks yeah and then stockx got in
trouble because they're selling a lot of
fakes
oh so so let's say i want to sell these
strange loves
i send it to stockx they have someone
ver verify them to make sure they're
real
well there are guys who are verifying
the fakes are so good now
they didn't know so they would give you
your shoes
and then the real secrets are like dogs
these are fake yeah
and they got in trouble yeah they're
getting sued for it
and then stockx also had a hiccup
because they leaked on accident they got
hacked
so a bunch of private information got
out they have problems
i think eminem mark wahlberg like
there's a bunch of investors in it
they're big time they're worth billions
oh yeah they're killing shout out to
stockx that's where i usually go
i don't know the difference with i like
goat too because goat you can buy you
shoes like i got my air max
safaris the air max 90 so far how's you
use these
not bad at all like they're usually like
they're kind of lightly worn but they
show you like the entire you get you get
a picture of the
shoe it's like these are the condition
they're like damn i'll take those for
half the price
yeah give me the used ones i do that all
the time oh i didn't know that
all the time oh oh they won't sound like
a busted pair of you shoes
i should sell them i use the slip-on
vans yeah i don't think so
i think people will buy that that's
vintage it is vintage they might do it
yeah i mean i'll [ __ ] sell them in a
heartbeat why not
what else yeah we are you still on true
detective season one
yeah stevie won't let me like binge
watch it all the way through and i will
only
watch it when i'm with him yeah so
yesterday we got to
i think we only have two episodes left
and i wanted to finish the last two but
he was like no
so good he's like i saw it i saw when it
came out
i remember thinking oh that that was
such a good show and then now i'm
watching it i'm like on the edge of my
seat and i look at my girl like
we watched this when it came out she
goes i don't remember anyway stevie's
the same i remember being good but it's
like i'm watching for the first time
it's so [ __ ] well done
yeah i watched all of them oh you guys
skipped see the other two season two but
it's not
all right season three was decent not as
good as one though no
they set the standards so high yeah
matthew mcconaughey's character
is so funny
his dad was a murderer serial killer oh
yeah that's right
i remember when it came out when he
started getting like really like
mainstream big and like the hunger games
and stuff like that someone did an
article when woody harrelson did
um what uh what was that movie natural
born killer after morning kill you got a
bunch of heat for it
because his dad was is this a jfk uh
well his his dad says he murdered jfk i
think he was a little crazy when he said
that okay
he might have been part of it because he
was in the mafia they had him on a tour
we went to dallas
yep it's so interesting i didn't know
that was woody harrelson has the quality
about him that's so
likeable and charismatic i love
introducing when he's going through the
biker bar and he puts the hat on like
white man can't jump like yeah [ __ ] yeah
dude
he's so good in that and i guess i gotta
check it out yeah he's great
on unreal i just should i just finished
cover first the first two episodes are a
little slow but dude once you get into
it
yeah like by the third one is he is he
in all the seasons woody
no no they change they change the
characters every every season
like american horse it was like second
one second one's so bad it makes you
never want to watch anything on hbo
pharaoh uh who else it's a girl it's
vince vaughn
it's so bad though the original writer
left that's why
i like that i like the intro song though
yeah
oh and the season five season one so
[ __ ] good
intro song all right i don't [ __ ] with
uh love island anymore
i don't either halfway through season
three and i was like me my girl i was
like i'm so
i thought i'd never hear this [ __ ]
dad i never thought i'd hear you put
your lighters out
well did they get the season uh 12
we'll see what happens but the old ones
aren't good
yeah it's hard to watch after watching
season five as the first
fight i was lit as [ __ ] yeah and i
started when we originally started no we
started with so we started with season
five
with the tour mike with the cop uh no
you guys watch half of season six and
then went to season five we started
through season five we started
we started with tommy fury yeah season
six with the twins five and six are good
mm-hmm everyone was like go make sure
you watch two and three yeah
two's okay all right he's off love
island yeah cause we haven't heard you
talk about it in a bit
a long time what happened to the water
bottle you still got the water bottle
still got the water
i'm drinking a lot of water these days
oh yeah that's good all right let's go
to current events
all right it's good have to peace so
much all the time can you go right now
no i'm all right all right yeah i told
you that water make you feed me
okay so kevin hart is currently in
a uh lawsuit with his personal shopper
he met a person who would basically go
out of their way to find
certain pieces that kevin hart wanted
but couldn't get
and he built up a rapport with kevin to
the point where he became
his personal shopper and he had access
to kevin hart's
uh credit cards and stuff like that and
he's only supposed to use it under the
guise of
i'm gonna buy you the items that you
want that you can't get
and so he's not supposed to use it for
anything else besides buying kevin hart
clothes
they found that he was uh using those
credit cards to buy stuff for himself
and he also started funneling money from
kevin's account
a million dollars worth of stuff he
bought art and
watches among other things well here's
the thing
400k of that in those y i think they're
ap watches or particularly
five for more than four hundred thousand
dollars
i think the takeaway from this is uh
cause collectible dolls okay
um i think they take away from this is
you you gotta stay on top of your [ __ ]
man
anytime i get a like anytime there's a
charge i get an alert on my phone
that's all i was just looking at oh
anytime like my girl whoever
anytime there's a charge i get an alert
but anytime chin does it i get an alert
anything chin buys equipment for the
studio because i was like how does that
happen like how do you
well i guess he was getting so much
money i guess and he just like didn't
pay attention to it i trusted that guy
trusted him
yeah still probably also trusted his
accountant or whoever it is that takes
care of his personal finances to
look over these things i wonder how he
caught it [ __ ] they probably they
probably went over things
like hey you know what what's all this
for and then went back through it it is
it could be like him just looking
through like his tax information like
what am i spending a million dollars on
and then he's like oh well like you're
shopping right like no dude you would
have had a job for the rest of your life
yeah
yeah why would you do that you would
have been set for a lot of people just
be so damn greedy thirsty
it's stupid not just greedy it's just
you're not being a good person
100 let's jump so what's it so he could
face up to 25 years in prison yup he
won't could
but yeah he probably won't because don't
seem like he push it that far
yeah just fire him but again in regards
do you get that money back
uh i don't know well you can sue him for
it but i don't know if he has million
yeah
he gets he had to get it back he might
just file for him
yeah yeah or just have him return all
the stuff that he bought although
that's another thing the police officers
have went and uh took back everything
that
they know that he still has that he
purchased with the money
and that's going to be going back to i
believe kevin
i'm sure yeah i gotta take patience
[Laughter]
all right here we go okay
so actress uh shane mitchell she's so
bad oh she's gonna
show you pretty little liars uh and doll
face
she was banning you i've never seen
anything else bro she's not also in
suits
she's not super never seen that she's
not in suits um meghan markle's hey
wait she's not in shoes no okay i'm
sorry
uh meghan markle the uh woman who
married prince you're right i'm thinking
of the other girl from peter
yeah um but she posted this photo uh
and she said it's basically before and
after photos she recently had a child
and she said that during quarantine she
threw her workout
program out the window and just kind of
started wearing sweatpants and eating
more
and she wanted to feel better and so she
started to do 30 minute workouts every
single day
for four weeks and this is her before
and after
but at the very end of it she ends up
posting something else
advertising a workout app and so a lot
of people are giving her
slack for this because they're saying
you just pose differently
on the same day we're putting your
shorts in a different way
she's not skinnier to make it yeah
people are saying that it's you're
angling it so you look skinnier than you
but it's the same photo these are fat
people who are upset damn people just so
damn
sad people are very are they saying
she's not in better shape after the four
weeks she looks weird
what they're saying is that she this
isn't before and after four weeks
they're saying that they think it's the
same day
she's just like she's stupid and
probably fat clearly she has a different
phone case
good job oh okay
doctor look different top different
makeup took off her necklace no
different necklaces
yeah you look at her body on the laptop
yeah now i like both but i'm just saying
she's she's clearly gotten better she'll
be with you i'm with you again this is
just
unhappy yeah
on the left love handles on the right
she handling her [ __ ]
i come with every now and again yeah i
feel like a lot of people on social
media are
like kind of touchy about celebrities
selling them like fitness stuff now
why they made it i don't know what it is
it seems like they just don't trust
there's no trust with celebrities
there's no trust with government there's
no
there's no trust got it i get it then
gotta talk [ __ ] about her
health is tight that's a hit
yeah are you serious thirty pounds what
should i get two you should get
that [ __ ] wait what no no i'm just
kidding
i'm just playing uh you're 2 58.
i would get to 225. i found a picture of
me when i was last in the 100 when the
last time i was in the hundreds what you
look like we're in seventh grade
man let people be themselves she want to
lose weight let her lose weight but
don't hate on her like she did nothing
how dare you look let me just tell you
something hawking
no i there's no one in shape talking
[ __ ] about this no
and also you can just tell look at her
nails it's pink the other ones is like
dark nude a little bit they're looking
too new to it she's definitely way
better looking
it's a little new it does look different
she got a little the lighting looks
different too it could be she got a
little sloppy she got a little sloppy
yeah yeah she had a baby quarantine
depression
food mm-hmm she's a bona fide bag two
different things
she was so like upset about because they
have nothing to do
everyone's trapped at home probably no
money they're just people aren't happy
yeah so you post her she's losing weight
they're not happy with their lives
[ __ ] you all right because even if she
did fake it and like
trying to sell an app who cares yeah if
you don't want it just don't buy it get
it
yeah i'm glad i have no friends that do
[ __ ] like that
you do i bet what that go on comment on
[ __ ]
oh malik hey look that's the last time i
was in uh the hunter get too much money
now to be coming out oh
church oh [ __ ] like church or jail
church or jail
i didn't i didn't know wesley snipes
stand up
is that wesley snipes had an open mind i
can't get right from life no that was at
a homie's uh wet
wedding oh he's actually marrying a
vietnamese uh
yeah still together nope
nope oh that's not that's just you
saying how much you care about him or
are you doing
yeah no i wasn't doing stand up i was
just saying how much i care about him
i think i got a fan in my pocket oh like
what
is going on yeah yeah i got one of those
in my pocket so i'm like
dude declan i think that was the last
time i was probably a racist fan
well look how big that [ __ ] shirt is
no bro you got that
kitty though you can wear that baggy
[ __ ] like that when you're big now you
wear that same thing you just you look
like a bouncer
i know i look just even bigger but see i
was rocking those adidas too like i had
a little bit of you know you got that
five heart beats little bit of swag
i think i was 16 right there did you get
them i go cut my
life in japanese this is this is my last
tweet
no it wasn't that song but no thank you
dark handy good night
i don't like burgers anymore
[Laughter]
now you gotta find one of you in the
hundreds
i don't know if there are pictures made
in the hundreds too like a high school
champion
yeah yeah 16 yeah that was probably the
last time i was in that i'm gonna be
about uh 200.
i was if you go to uh brent job
metamoris i was probably two i was 222
there
met her more morris too yeah yep what's
that is this
jiu-jitsu tournament if you
go to look thinner there
yeah i'm like 222. oh damn wow you do
look skinny
you look different you want to get back
to that uh
i mean 222 would be great listen i was
training jiu jitsu
six hours a day yeah i'm not doing that
go to that one we had the uh
the jack know you look skinny right
there this one yeah
that's me talking [ __ ] to him are you
talking [ __ ] did you talk sh you talk
[ __ ]
me and him when i had it yeah that dude
looks so much bigger than you yeah he
was
what kind of [ __ ] you be talking yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i want to help you
no he was talking [ __ ] from me no he's
talking [ __ ] to me
oh he was saying that i didn't engage in
[ __ ] but i shut him down
would you say he was mad that i didn't
like he didn't submit me
he's like one of the greatest jiu-jitsu
guys of all time oh look at you there
yeah that's me there where's that at
santa monica yeah
well in the biker shorts tights you've
been about that life huh
yep i can't wait to get in mine and you
beat this guy
no i went to a draw oh god i had him
right there
and he was talking [ __ ] after the fight
yeah that's why he was saying i didn't
engage in [ __ ] that's me just locking
him the [ __ ] down
look he's trying everything what is he
trying to do right here get my leg
oh dang v yeah that's me dominating him
it's called the shop shut down and then
we get a leg up get out
get back let's go
bro they got this on youtube i'm sure
it's not the most exciting one though
oh it's not it's me slapping the show
like you trying to get them to do
something
like you healing them a little bit yeah
yeah it does look like that
yeah i don't like mints anymore i don't
like bins anymore
all right what else we got jen you like
women women women okay
so uh dave chappelle announced in a
10-minute clip on instagram that
after his last uh instagram clip talking
about how we should boycott him
and the chappelle show uh everything was
taken down
from netflix and they actually read he
renegotiated with viacom and now he's
getting paid properly yep he's gonna
yeah
so now they put it back they're gonna
put it back off wait it was a clip
yeah it was a clip he because he only he
don't post much on that
instagram page of his but like it's like
a 10 minute clip basically
he's playing it yeah he just yeah
basically explaining what uh
what kind let me see let me see this
video
the fans can see this right he doesn't
really talk about it until like
oh it's ten minutes long yeah too long
though you know
you need to know where your power lies
oh this symptom
yeah so your power lies
in each other
is that snubs barbecue that's a venue in
austin a few weeks ago i put a special
out i called it unforgiving i told
people what my beef was with comedy
central i never talked about it i
demanded that the network
paid me many of my peers laughed at me
because that's a ridiculous thing to
demand they said well you signed the
contract so what are you even mad about
here's the thing i'm very good
at minding my own business and the trick
to minding your own business
is knowing what is your business
and these people that talk about me
these cowards
yeah they rejoice preach well they don't
understand what greatness looks like
oh i never asked comedy central for
anything
if you remember i said i'm going to my
real boss
and i came to you because i know where
my power lies
i ask you to stop watching the show and
thank
god almighty for you you did
you made that show worthless because
without your eyes
it's nothing and when you stop watching
it
they called me and i wrote my name back
and i got my license back and i got
my show back and they paid me
millions of dollars thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
when i took 12 years off and you put me
right back on top when i came back
i couldn't thank you enough you have
kept me free
i have not had to do what so many of my
colleagues have to do
because of you i have no idea what dicks
taste like
this is a very important moment i want
to thank ted sarandos at netflix the ceo
who had the courage
to take my show off its platform and
financial detriment to his company
just because i asked him well he knows
and i want to thank chris mccarthy
of cbs viacom this guy is younger than
me
and like most people younger than me has
an interest in making the past
right and did something that was very
courageous
and finally after all these years i can
finally
say to comedy central it's been a
pleasure
oh yeah and then it's just
low it's hard little montage clips maybe
just
writes it or something oh there it is oh
no it's just coming back
the netflix is going to back up yeah i
thought he was doing a new oh and
i thought of first two oh yeah okay well
it's not that exciting
i've seen all of them you know i thought
was doing redoing it
oh no that was important what he said
though the people are the part that's
what the
judas and the black messiah the guy fred
hampton was saying like yo when there's
people there's power something 100
100 that's the bosses that's the real
boss so yeah that that's with everything
that you even
with this canceled culture like you look
at brian's situation
you can't cancel brian if there's still
uh
avenue for him you can't cancel yeah any
evidence if the fans still buy tickets
to stand up which they're doing
if they're still watching these podcasts
which they're doing you you should you
just can't
because the people is the people the
people the market dictates
not these big businesses correct
especially in the podcast and stand-up
space
well think about like i always think
about mark norman like
you know doing his own special on
youtube these guys that are putting
their specials out
on youtube yeah they're taking ownership
they're taking ownership instead of
going through these [ __ ]
companies you know and like just getting
rejected rejected
meanwhile it's like yo like i know what
it's like when i go out and do these
shows
correct fans show the [ __ ] up yeah i
know people want to see the standard
special i know that i mean yeah i know
what's funny and what what my fans
consider funny and i think this is good
enough to put out as a special yeah
and so if netflix or showtime contents
were like no we're good it's like all
right cool
i'll do it myself and put on youtube
yeah because i know there's this
audience that will watch it yeah and
also he probably gained more
from it because it's on youtube it's in
there and it's in there
when you go around the man yeah
and it just makes you want to support
that person even more
what's the what's the saying in
hollywood it takes so many notes to get
that one yes
you know i mean so the door keeps
shutting and shutting and then yeah
yeah that's with acting but i hear you i
hear you
well i was following you yeah what else
you got
so we talked about the woman with the
gorilla glue in her hair last
show uh she actually saw a doctor who
offered to
help her okay he's based out of beverly
hills yes he managed to
help her with her situation and a few
days after
her video went viral there was a man in
louisiana people thought it was fake
who thought it was fake and he wanted to
prove a point
he said that it's more of a black person
thing huh
let's be real there's not white people
doing this [ __ ] to their hair and lips
is that fair is that racist
so black people have gorilla glue and
then white people have it [ __ ] with
animals
yeah you don't you don't see a lot of
white babies like i put this
gorilla glue in my hair basically what
you're saying is black people we got
gorilla glue white people i got elmer
glue that's what
you know what you're saying right now
that's what you said white people don't
even [ __ ] with elmer glue i know i
remember it was some white kids that put
on their hands
yeah y'all had that yeah i guess
maybe smell this it's not like a fad
like this is like you see
i don't think this is a fad i think yeah
it's stupid i really thought that she
was trying to like get on the internet
and get famous for
faking that gorilla
[Applause]
record a video for him and he was gonna
prove a point saying i'm gonna put
gorilla glue on my mouth and i'm gonna
drink out of a cup all i'm gonna need to
do is lick my lips and the gorilla glue
is gonna come off
they shut off right as he's taking a sip
and the next
footage that you see is a photo of him
in the hospital all right
that's hilarious hold on what
so it does that sometimes oh
[Music]
[Music]
great camera wall i think you want to
show his face
wait no he does no it does i just think
he has a choice
put it on here he said put it on here
put it on here put on here
so it stops there yeah
brown was lying ended up emergency room
after you believe he could apply girl
glued a red solo cup
just lip and lick it they had to slowly
peel it off and it was
so incredibly painful but they're saying
that if they couldn't get all of the
leftover remnants of the glue off he's
gonna have to go through
surgery and his lip may be permanently
damaged he then made a statement saying
this is not a trick please don't do it
it's louisiana that picture is hilarious
i know honey that's a meme
that's a meme though his cheeks are all
there
that's they're standing where you going
doctor can you help
[Laughter]
but i did see a barber uh i think it was
a black over
or white barber being like i use grilled
glue all the time with my
uh like people all the time what do you
mean it's all my life
you showed him like doing it yeah he was
like i use it all the time i don't know
what the [ __ ] everybody's talking about
you should be careful with it was this
on worldstar i think so
look at that guy
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] image is so
uh glad they got that [ __ ] off them
um this is drake reacting to his old
co-star from degrassi junior high
was it degrassi junior higher than
degrassi high or something like that
yeah or whatever
her busted children remember watching oh
she's a baddie hopefully
she don't see oh get there i can't play
the music but that's her
bust it she can't do it kind of goofy
right oh yeah and then my butt getting
big
and then bam so that's an outfit that
she wore in degrassi that was like her
character she was known as kind of like
the
the [ __ ] character of the school she
wore the like thong with the low
uh jeans what did drake say
you know what it's in the first page
here we go
there that's dope
does anyone get this or no yeah he's
just referring to her as her character
that's it well that's dope did you guys
ever watch
alaskan bush people no oh uh discovery
channel i know what it is
the father passed away this guy at 68.
no it's very sad this guy's your current
event yeah i'm serious this is a huge
show
it's a huge show yeah but look at him
he's 68 though i mean he lives in alaska
as a bush person so he's not going to
live in a regular
city wait so what's the show about it's
living in like in the remote
he passed away from loneliness i bet
seizure
yeah he's 68 though he's six years young
68's fairly yeah yeah it is young um we
already have the jj watt one
uh that guy that did the streaking yeah
he said he got 300
370 000 for it yeah he did the streaking
because he bet
like he put all this money out told
everyone about streaker at the super
bowl so he just bet on himself
the street one got got out of jail and
got the money
damn so great yeah good for him always
bet on yourself man
indeed kind of um
there's a gina carano one did you hear
about the gina chrono one yes please go
to it
okay so um oh the actress yeah
so she's just very like you guys know
about gina chrono she used to be an mma
fighter correct
world champion strikeforce fighter she
was like she didn't get enough credit
she'd be on the mount rushmore female
fighters
she was before rhonda she was the first
dime piece she got beat up by cyborg
didn't get annihilated we got beat up by
cyborg she was a beast her dad was a
backup quarterback for dallas cowboys oh
[ __ ]
transitioned from a strikeforce champion
to hollywood
she's been fast and furious mandalorian
but then when covet hit she started to
tweet out some stuff
where it gets dicey because you know she
got cancelled right so there's hashtag
you know fire gina chrono from menlo and
it became super trending from the far
left they wander out of there
it's tough to cancel someone based off
their political beliefs
we got to be careful with that
where i don't agree with her is relating
you know
what the the government's doing with
lockdown
comparing it to the nazis that's where
she got in trouble oh she competed in
nazis yeah yeah
and but and then she and then she uh
can't just do
that she got some more [ __ ] because
she's talking about pronouns and putting
her bio bebop boop
being like you know just making fun of
it yeah but she was like i'm not making
fun of it she was like i'm just saying
how ridiculous it is
oh and then she changed it she said i
wasn't aware that i would upset so many
people so she changed it she learned
from the
transgender community she changed it the
nazi stuff's a little tough
yeah was that was that was that in
within recent oh yeah it was like
last week yeah or maybe like even like a
few days ago i've been this week and
that's that's when lucasfilm's like all
right we can't yeah they dropped her
immediately yeah she can't you can't
just and she posted jeff's
jeff epstein didn't kill himself that's
fine if she believes that she she don't
get canceled over that
but she doesn't get dicey with the nazis
it's just like the jews
but also what are you thinking i know
it's hollywood what are you doing you
can't i think disney also has to be a
little more
like precautious about nazi stuff
because disney does have like a
background with
being he does yeah pro-nazi yeah so
they're probably even more sensitive
about it
yeah yeah it's just super super heavy
that you can't compare something like
political injustice to something that
you're putting people into freaking you
know they're burning them alive and
stuff
it's just too much yeah it's a far far
reach
um yeah do i think she lost her job on
star wars
no so she's actually doing a movie with
uh you know ben shapiro
he's a very popular political guy so
they hired her to do like a movie about
her life
she's right after this this is her
fighting back from getting canceled
yeah it's a bomber that social media can
create such a
a wave that to the point that you can
lose your job over but
at first i was like all right this
ridiculous she got fired they look into
like the nazis
she's a super dime piece you should just
never say that yeah one of the baddest
yes yeah she's one of the baddest [ __ ]
baddest best and baddest
mount rushmore her rachel ostovich she's
up
she's so yeah
she goes they can't cancel if we don't
let them yeah she's right
she has a lot of support too another
cancelled person
morgan wallen uh he's not canceled i
mean for now it's tough to cancel morgan
wallin because
for saying the n-word all the stations
dropped him but the
his purchases on itunes went through the
roof
because because the world like again the
people decide
if you have a career or not so the
people are like yeah we
he made a mistake he's a talented dude
he learned from it we down
we his music like went through the
[ __ ] roof downloads went through the
roof
let's be honest his fan base watches a
lot of nascar so
him saying n word i i don't think he's a
bad guy
you know i don't know him personally i
know theo knows him um
i you know him saying that isn't going
to make me stop listening to his music
if you said it and it said it different
way yeah a different way
you got to be ready for those
repercussions yes yeah super ready but i
mean
he still shouldn't this day and age you
should know not to say that though
he was on a public platform yeah he
didn't know he's been filming of course
never filmed it they filmed it from
their ring
so should it be canceled for that
well yeah that's crazy that they're
taking them off pretty much all the all
the radio stations
but the itunes thing is
the audience decides if he's cancelled
yeah of course not these radio stations
i'm with the audience too man like now
if apple pulled his music it's like come
on dude you got charles manson on there
you got all this [ __ ] on there what are
you doing yeah
that bam margera one for jackass tough
to watch have you seen that video
no talked about suicidal thoughts
he's been really really going down they
did jackass foreign comment on bam
it's because bam's not sober and they
wanted bam part of jackass for but they
wanted to do all this stuff like drug
testing
yeah make sure he takes medication he
didn't agree to it so like i can't be
part of it
he's just spiraling out of control he's
calling for a boy that doesn't end well
i love them dude everyone was younger
yeah
but you're you're not like if you're if
you allow them to come on and you don't
do the drug test you're kind of allowing
him to continue doing what he's doing
and yeah you're enabling
you don't want to do that either yeah so
it's kind of like he has to go through
this click
and it's not like they go it's not like
they didn't want him a part of it they
want him
i don't think they don't want him in
that state yeah they're like they're
trying to help him
you know quiet yeah click on
yeah it's it three minutes who the [ __ ]
cares if i'm drunk as hell or not
anymore jackass has put me through
[ __ ]
hell on [ __ ] wheels for a year and a
half
keeping me in pennsylvania i couldn't
leave
if i left or else i had to breathe in
the
sobriety length every day
six o'clock eight o'clock then a random
beep would go off no matter where i was
at i had to [ __ ] stop whatever i was
doing
and good with urgent care to go piss
then i had to wake up every day full of
anti-depressant pills that i would have
to show paramount pictures
that i took them and swallowed them
every single day
stevo has been sober as [ __ ] since
since 10 years if he had a breath like
he's gonna
go camping one day and not have any
internet reception
he's gonna sleep through one or two he's
got like people
they set me up with such a [ __ ] hard
mission
that and then covet happen for a year
against anyone's knowledge
like so now i had to spend 90
000 in a rehab for 90 days
at my expense i had to go to 30 days in
florida for a rehab at my expense
i had to pay for therapists that they
recommended
that they spent but i had to pay for it
i have what b
malik b i wrote them so many ideas and
if i'm not in the movie
and they use my ideas how do you think
that that'll make me feel the last thing
i want to do is be in a courtroom with
jeff
[ __ ] germain i love him what the
[ __ ] man i'm not in jackass for if
anybody cares about me
don't go see their movie because i will
make mine way
[ __ ] radder if you've just been
mowing me a dollar just
me a dog he starts throwing up
here really yeah he doesn't remember his
name write it down
he said more than that no more
no i'm so relieved
why are you still filming himself doing
that yeah why would he edit this i guess
i didn't see why don't you edit that oh
so anyway then mow me your money and
i'll create jackass folks but
[ __ ] [ __ ] you jeff you [ __ ] never
cared about me man
she said [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh yeah [ __ ] bummer man
[Music]
throwing up that was he yeah that was
funny because he wanted to save
i know you broke my heart he's going
through it man yeah
i hope he gets out you can see how
johnny knoxville and steve are like
we can't have if you're not sober we
can't have you because everyone is sober
yes and you got a job to do man
you can't you know you can't be [ __ ]
up on set no matter
what crazy [ __ ] they're doing it's
heartbreaking
yeah what else you got jen
um this right here these are rumors dr
dre and april jones april jones who was
omarion's girl bro yeah
and she went through the game yeah
wouldn't be up
mm-hmm might be next they were spotted
essentially
apparently spotted together she's bad
man super she has a new tattoo on my
stomach
[Applause]
hey what's up jay how you doing tonight
man
oh this brenda's website the shade room
uh-huh dre will fans ever get a chance
to hear a chronic three or a detox
anytime soon
we'd love to hear you open up the vaults
and uh and release some of that music
man i'm a huge fan
thank you appreciate it okay crooked
cops is one of my favorite records i'd
love it
if you would release that yeah but beau
is oh a steakhouse yeah bruh
noah is popping that's like the one
place that all internet celebrities and
regular celebrities are going to eat
me and my shirt he went there wait wait
did she just leave little fizz
how she going oh
bro i think when these girls get popular
i think they just get ran through the
industry
no no and again i don't want to take
those treads lightly but they start
dating the same rappers it's weird
though
like there's so many beautiful women out
there why are the same one always like
i think they almost are such a baddie
yeah but i mean there's so many holidays
out there
april such a bad bad let me see what she
looks like april john
i i personally well i'm not gonna say it
here though thank thank god omarion is
like zen
because that uh man look at bow wow baby
mama joey chavez
and then she got passed around and then
future got her had a baby
yeah i have my thoughts on this but you
don't think she's hatching
uh then when she was walking she looked
pretty tight but this right here not my
style really
yeah you don't like hot girls no man
that's basically what it is
no it's not what it is
you think she's gorgeous oh my god yes
yes it's really why dre is
with her what do you think she's
gorgeous yeah she's bad i got another
picture
why oh you just think it's i mean yeah
she's bad got another pick
any pic you go into the same picture she
already knows okay
another one playing a good time she
plays guitar that's just a bad photo
shoot no i think [ __ ] we should jam with
her
chill out you know damn what she's doing
she looks great right here
we can't post one picture my gosh
doesn't she look terrible here
but you guys aren't being honest i don't
think you guys are being honest when i
was looking at that picture you think
she's
do you think she's ugly no but i'm
saying like what are you doing
all these for all these powerful people
to be like i just need this girl right
here but that's what they do though like
um i brought up baby go to balwa go to
joey chavez real quick
joey yeah so she's had she had a baby
with bow wow
she was dating uh not j i j i
j g what joey
j o joy yeah whatever her name is
charles yeah
man it's j-o-i-e i think um i don't know
it's a weird name yeah
i think that's but anyways what about
her anyways well she get passed around
by
uh she went first by wildstar that's his
baby mom
then she broke up with him and she
started dating an nfl player
then she went to a basketball player
then future got her and he was like man
i gotta have a baby
well i i think these girls have a type
two right they're like powerful
successful black men
and those right into those dm's but also
dr dre is in the business and i'm sure
people like dude she's such a
monster in bed and he's like hell yeah
well that's why they talk they talk dude
yeah they only have them for a little
bit yeah i could you good
oh yeah i could not hold a half yeah she
been with her yeah you know she's with
all these
like what the hell everyone has a pass
but at the same time like every girl in
hollywood is kind of dating the same
couple of guys too that's what i'm
saying it's like like future always has
like a bunch of like models around him
and it's like the same ones yeah what
another person yeah i feel like it's one
of those things when you watch gossip
girl everyone eventually dates each
other yeah it's like that yeah that's
what happens when you're
i think dudes talk more than women like
dudes like hey bro she bad this she do
she do this for you she's like and then
there's like hell yeah so that's why
they kind of like
but also put yourself in that situation
if you had a chance to date any one of
these girls would you not take your
opportunity to do so if it was my turn
yeah why is it a problem that she's
dating all these guys
it's not a problem
victor cruz i don't care who's victory
oh you mean she dated dudes
yeah she had sex with him yeah that's
what people do you have you come into a
relation it's no relationship you're
going to meet someone and and she's a
ver well they're out there
but is it do you really want a version
no no no
not saying that no no i'm not saying
that at all that's not what he's saying
i'm saying
why do you need to have this particular
girl when there's so many beautiful
awesome girls out there well some of
these girls know this like their
lifestyle
like maybe that's what i'm saying that
has been today okay so she's come from
that world like you know
i'm talking about the point yeah that
world so he's like she know the business
she know what it is
she know what i'm doing she ain't gonna
blow my face all right okay i'll give
you that i'll give you that i'll give
you that like she's gonna be a headache
yeah she's all right
hey bro like there's a i'm sure there's
hotter girls than her like
let's see he gets some instagram thought
and then she goes crazy she's posting
videos
they break up she starts slamming all
right that's a great point yeah that's a
very great point
look at her in that video she did not be
in the camera she's right behind him she
knew what she's like she didn't post
about it anyway
yeah all right absolutely all right i'll
give you that yeah
we're doing okay so now that you've been
doing this
yeah broke out great advice you know the
deal bro
[Laughter]
we gotta end with some love advice for
the valentine's day special
yeah which one you want to do first
let's do this this one says yo malik so
i'm 21 and i'm dating this girl
who keeps bringing up marriage but i
feel
we're way too young to even be he's 21
yet we're way too young
but i could see myself being married to
this girl in the future the problem is
i'm still young and i'm trying to get in
some other
coochies
should i just anchor down with my queen
let me know dr love
uh twenty one i was about 21. that's so
young you talking about marriage at 21
what were you doing at 21.
getting [ __ ] up trying to figure life
out that you definitely shouldn't be
married no yeah
listen 21 is a great age for a promised
ring give her a little promise ring
yeah you give her a little promise right
yeah even though
even that 21 no even that i mean you're
just getting into the thick of it my man
yeah there's gonna be so many hoes
headed your way at 21 22 23 24 25.
yeah yeah 27 all right twenties yeah
that's when they started talking yeah
but here's the if she's a baddie and she
checks every box i don't know
i've been there before it doesn't matter
listen let me just see how long they've
they've been together
no it doesn't let me just tell you you
also use the word coochie so yeah if
she's 20
if she's 23 or younger let me know that
now she's bad
you're gonna pay for every goddamn thing
you don't you understand she's bad she
can't have anything
you don't if you don't she's gonna find
time for that thank you what was that
for chris brown when a rich dude wants
you whatever
what can your man do daniel
come on
yes
on me no maybe she has to go flap her
wings somewhere else man yeah yeah
bro 21 is way too say anchor down my
queen nah she tried to get anchored down
by you pimp
no it sounds like she is though but
there's me with an anchor kangaroo
uh no problem i also have love doctor
questions how much do you spend on an
engagement ring i'm bawling on a butt
i'm balling on a budget so you're not
bothered yeah my girl doesn't care about
fancy things but i want to get her
something nice what do you think
ball out or the cheap way who can bring
it up on cutting weight or firing the
kids
rolly rolly f big sean now big sean just
put his house for sale for 15 million
so that's cool you guys aren't the same
same bracket same bracket yeah
definitely worried about your disc
followed on a budget yeah ball on the
b.o.b b.o.b i mean so so here's the
thing
it goes to like how long you've been
with her you know and then an engagement
ring you don't ball on a budget on the
cage memory
no you're the only one who's married
here but girl girls dig the rings huh
yes yeah they love skipping i feel like
dudes don't really give a [ __ ] about a
ring but you can't ball on a budget
though
that's the thing you got to go all out
because you know girls love rings
you like expensive rings would you like
not really i don't really like flashy
jewelry it's just a personal preference
i do think people like the symbol that
some women do like fancy jewelry
yeah it's like certain guys with nice
watches you know i heard there's a new
day and age that now this new generation
there's like let's just get matchy
tattoos on the ring finger yep
that's what brendan that's our new
generation that'd been awesome my bad
idea
he was there on that road date by the
way he was you were there it was dallas
you're right i apologize but uh good i
hate rings
you hate rings hate rings but it's more
of a woman's thing yes yeah
did you get your girl a ring right yes
and you didn't ball on the budget you
ain't seen that ring
oh nice you always see the house i saw
the castle i saw the castle
you didn't see that i see it i didn't
see it it felt like coming to america
yeah we are here it's a lot of money for
for nothing
it's it's silly yeah it's not like you
could ever sell it back or anything you
can sell it back people do it all the
time but it's an ego thing
yeah well i said get a great ring and if
things don't work out take it back
take that [ __ ] take that i'll show you
your girl's not a jeweler so if you get
one that's not it's clear but it's
bigger
do that man you know there's a tick-tock
trend where uh there's a guy he has one
of those like diamond
uh diamond tester the diamond testers he
goes around to his school asking
teachers like
oh do you who got you this ring like are
you married
these rings and some of them will turn
out fake and afterwards he'll record
the woman like hey i have a kid in here
that's my diamond like yeah
have you seen a video what a legend
with their shoes like the uh jordans and
[ __ ] i mean like
they'd have to be so good at spotting
that oh yeah they'll do it in the blue
lights
i've seen people doing it like i
remember there's two guys with fake
jordan jerseys at a chicago game and
they just they've
gotten the big tron and people just
clown them because they're two fake
jordan jerseys
they didn't know it they're two off
brown jordan
they're like what the [ __ ]
you got to see this real quick that's
the funniest thing when they are these
old teachers cussing out their husbands
no hell not in the middle like
they take a break from class and then
hell no i got the student in here
and he films it all it's so funny he
turns around he's recording like get out
of here
you're good yeah i don't [ __ ] i don't
[ __ ] with diamonds right here
uh tick tock but uh i just sent him to
youtube you got to change
i know yeah no i don't like i don't like
much jewelry like that i do like the
gold chain
yeah i do like the chains i hate rings
yeah i'm not a watcher
i love watches i hate watches i don't
think i can get into to be honest
you don't seem like you're watching yeah
just on my [ __ ] wrist chilling like
that hey jack
what about earrings would you like
something some double studded diamond
earrings i mean i got my ear spears
right here still the holes
[Music]
that was a style in the 90s i got these
piers in first grade
they never closed first grade your pants
pushed you to do that no i wanted it i
said give me them first
which parents what
yeah all right you think it's real
yeah of course i mean let me test it
yeah
[Music]
is that real yeah it's a real diamond
tester
why is his nails so long that's fake
yeah okay
all right that's fake what all right
we're back for part three
so you think all three of these is real
yeah that is a big all right
all right this one really this one she
all right so you think these are
diamonds right here they're not i think
they're gems
let's see what she says it's not popping
up or anything
that's not the binding yeah but try
these
black ones this one yeah this is a
diamond it's black foreign
all right let me just get that where
where is it
what about the little ones here watch
his fingernails so long go back go back
[Laughter]
all right all right i told you it was
real
i didn't know it's kind of small but
it's small
if it wasn't another file for divorce
already
[Music]
all right divorce now let's see the ring
all right you ready yeah sure
yeah people don't know look at this
all right all right i told you you lucky
this time
testing dom is part six now great video
man
i know which one you're talking yeah god
damn there's a few that you don't you
sent me this
i know right but at the same time we
should have had a clip
wait the crying emoji yeah they broke up
this is what teachers like
oh we'll talk about it we get home oh
really yeah real black owner
um legit stuff i don't know
my show's
[Laughter]
27th cleveland march 11th through the
13th tickets at
f a t k z dot com thick boy gear oh
we're doing a giveaway on
sunday for thick boy the same designer
who did my helmet we got a thick boy
giveaway for the helmet
the way you win is by signing up to
thick boy newsletter you can sign up at
thickboy.com
and you'll double your chances to win if
you purchase uh
merchandise from thickboy.com and then
they randomly pick a winner
it's a signed thick boy uh custom helmet
signed by me i'm gonna get into that get
you yeah i think i might
tampa you're up though tampa florida
february 26th 27th then march 11th march
13th
cleveland get your tickets at fatkz.com
or on my social media
is that it kids yeah what's up man yeah
february 25th through the 27th
kansas city i think i found my barbecue
spots that i'm gonna go to
i think i'm gonna hit up q39 yeah we've
been over this and then uh march 5th
dude no i didn't say it last time i was
deciding no we decided
march is your diet that is true
you know you [ __ ] up right
you said you said you was gonna die yeah
you had the broccoli
shout out q39 order if i get it you say
you trust the sword with mark harley see
i can't even go i can't even go to
barbecue joints just kidding i'm not
going to barbecue
uh find me i'll find a trainer i'm gonna
find a trainer in kansas that's what i'm
gonna do
and then uh love is type merge i just
had some new merch drop i know i'm gonna
do that
right there where is
for the whole valentine's weekend so go
ahead and get that uh that merge
uh thank you guys um
uh uh that blue shirt one time yeah and
that's it
that was it all those everything that's
all i got damn
you know what we think more hoodies i
got i know i give you a ton of [ __ ]
that's cool man
i tried to say one right chapelle lacy
getting crazy but never high off that
space
you know what i'm saying uh i got the
what are these called again
come on now yeah uh
love is tight what's up malik b aka
rolly boy
you know i appreciate chin tend to get
in hey look i got the chunky dunks you
feel me
yeah yeah get all this yeah
also get over your pants then look at
the hoodie look at this hoodie from
suplex
shout out to everybody from suplex bro
much love
get that 272. yeah what's up dude all
272.
268 holla hashtag 272.
it's valentine's day you [ __ ]
strange love collabs
that crush velvet crushing hearts
crushing
crushing hearts crushing farts there you
go broccoli
[Laughter]
bye guys